Congratulations, you have
seen how one problem,
satisfiability, captures all of the
complexity of the P versus NP problem.
An efficient algorithm for
satisfiability when imply P equals NP.
If P is different from NP, then it
can't be any efficient algorithm for
satisfiability.
Satisfiability has efficient algorithms
if, and only if, P equals NP.
Steve Cook,
professor of the University of Toronto,
presented his theorem on May 4, 1971,
at the symposium on the the theory of
computing at the then Stouffer's Inn
in Shaker Heights, Ohio.
But his paper didn't have an immediate
impact as a satisfiability problem
was mainly of interest to logicians.
Luckily a Berkeley professor,
Richard Karp, also took interest, and
realized that you use satisfiability
as the starting point.
If you can reduce satisfiability
to another NP problem,
then our problem must
be NP complete as well.
Karp did exactly that, and a year
later he published his famous paper,
Reducibility Among
Combinatorial Problems,
showing that 21 well-known combinatorial
search problems were also MP complete,
including the clique problem.
Today tens of thousands of problems
have been shown to be MP complete.
The ones that come up the most often are
practiced tend to be closely related to
one of Karp's originals.
In the next lesson, we'll examine
some of the reductions that prove
these classic problems to be MP complete
and try to convey a general sense for
how to go about finding such reductions.
This sort of argument might come in
handy if you need to convince someone
that a problem isn't as easy
to solve as they might think.